[Music]
yeah alright sounds thérèse put it in
the kitchen
Sandra is in debt why haven't you got
your heater on because we can't afford
to put it on that's why I don't get paid
till after January the second week in
January still have to go without
it'll don't want when family call me
don't go bad in her case because of an
error in overpaid benefits benefits she
now has to pay back oh my goodness she's
so sweet
until the debts cleared it's almost hard
what she has left to spend on food with
a granddaughter coming to stay her
finances can't stretch to feed another
mouse five pounds a week
Dix gets 14 backfist 14 dinners and 14
teas at the moment I have five pounds
away to get 21 blacklist 2110 it and
plays warranties put that any pot could
you do it because I grass debt is an
invisible burden being carried by the
country's most vulnerable I've just
thrown in some cereal and some little
toys and that yeah you research for Sky
News shows just how big a burden that is
right three kids many here in Rock Ferry
Merseyside rely on crisis handouts just
to make ends meet with many borrowing
simply to live I am in debt which I am
paying off and I'm covering that it's
coming out of my wages and go into debt
currently due to my past circumstances
I'm struggling so much that loans I have
three children 12 14 17 we aren't sure
how we will get through questioners for
the first time food donations here can't
meet the calls for help
this is neo community house in the heart
of rock Ferry in Birkenhead its
volunteers catching families in crisis
sorrows bus
a suggested donation of 150 people pay
what they can afford to stretch their
budgets before borrowing they offer food
warmth and advice to people dealing with
debts they can eat for free
you know that's what we do we want
cheering anybody away
they're now helping more working
families than they are people on
benefits low incomes simply too low to
make ends meet
I've been out and bought a two-year-old
about help me own money couple months
ago some of them really gets here some
of them you can walk away from you can
help them and walk away on some behavior
or polar night in tears as we're
speaking ally realizes an emergency
delivery for a new mum has been left
behind a baby is crying as we speak
because it's got no milk a shot a five
week old baby who's starving
these are problems they deal with every
day of the year every time you go to
lock the door you've got another one
pulling up outside around Christmas
there's just more of it more calls from
people needing loans electricity food
the baby formula eventually makes it to
Makayla she had a baby girl five weeks
ago but a maternity pay hasn't been paid
along with her growing pile of bills
fees and explain the situation that he's
been it's been tough enough for Makayla
as a single mom on a low income but no
maternity pay at Christmas pushed her
into mounting debt with a newborn and an
11 year old Stephen Dolph Dolph to
actually know that there's a problem we
can see them except where she can't so
or it just it really looks at me because
it just adds to the stress of war I'm
already going through and it's not like
I don't wake away a card and what that
do you have a council tax
which debates yeah I am I just started
text and I've got I haven't got it and
the only thing I've got is tally and you
know welcome to come and take it but
you'll be taking it from me soul and he
didn't have sorry for me but I'm just
worried you know daddy gonna show off at
any point and actually don't answer the
door like you know if people not had an
accident like Sandra Michaela's in debt
because of a bureaucratic error that for
people in average salaries would be
manageable but for people experiencing
poverty it can be a crisis research done
for Sky News shows the poorest 10% of
households with a debt spend a third
thirty four percent of their gross
income on repayments that's more than
three times the case for average
household incomes and 31 percent of
people experiencing hardship use loans
to finance day-to-day spending that's
bills food simply living and among this
demographic 32% are already having
difficulties keeping up with debt
repayments again these figures much
higher than for those on average incomes
so where can people turn for help one
offer has come to Makayla in the form of
a letter from loan company Provident it
sells the picture of a perfect Christmas
along with loans at five hundred and
thirty five percent
Merseyside is home to some of the
poorest parts of the country and these
letters offering doorstep loans are
falling through letter boxes in the most
deprived areas like Rock Ferry
the high levels of interest to finance
lending to high-risk customers
debt isn't a deprivation issue but
affordable credit is the main difference
being if you have money you can borrow
relatively cheaply from a bank or credit
card but if you're scraping by who's
there to sub you for people experiencing
poverty two of the main sources of cash
at doorstep loans and loan sharks and
when finances are really stretched
around Christmastime these money lenders
are targeting some of the poorest
streets in the country unlike loan
sharks companies like Provident are
legal and provide credit that otherwise
wouldn't exist for many people but the
debt can spiral frightening new out of
control
we said once I paid so much off I could
have another one Mary took out a 300
pound Provident loan last Christmas
then another she doesn't want to be
identified so we've changed her name
what are the repayments about fifty five
pounds on earth are you paying them no I
couldn't afford a I couldn't afford it
so what's happening and a few getting
letters of different bailiff companies
Mary is also a single mum and doesn't
have family nearby for help but you
don't need to look far in Birkenhead to
see the alternatives
traditionally loans were funded by the
states or friends and family but those
safety nets don't exist anymore for most
people and a new industry has grown to
fill that hole Provident is the biggest
provider of doorstep loans and home
credit in the country with four hundred
and forty thousand customers we went to
see them at their office in Birkenhead
but they didn't want to speak to us they
did send us a statement though and said
our customers need access to credit to
live their lives we lend responsibly our
customers know what they need to pay
back as the amount they repay is fixed
at the outset voice recording now takes
place and our customer visits to ensure
we have treated our customers fairly
many people here have taken doorstep
loans to make ends meet
the interest is high but it's been
capped by law since 2015
but loan sharks preying on vulnerable
communities around the country are
criminals and set their own terms we've
been told they are operating here but
fear stops people telling us much more
than that their enforcement methods can
be frightening
we believe that loan sharks are
operating in most communities but here
the tables have turned the illegal money
lending team are about to doorstep a
loan shark in leads with an arrest
warrant when we get there
the suspect claims he's locked in and
his wife's gone out with the key okay
where's your wife have you found her
you don't have a phone yeah okay if you
don't open the door we're going to force
entry his wife then appears with the key
I am working part of the National legal
money lending team you're now under
arrest and this one yes right the man
arrested on suspicion of operating as a
loan shark was later released and
inquiries are continuing it's estimated
325 million pounds is borrowed from loan
sharks every year and more than 700
million paid back the interest so high
one man borrowed 1500 pounds and
paid more than sixty thousand this is
what we see time and time again they
portray themselves as your best friend
they portray yourself portray themselves
and they get into your psyche that
they're a friend
what sort of interests are they charge
and we see we see interest
APR 15 2014 1 towards people who can't
repay those that we've seen everything
from assaults to wound in kidnapping and
even as far as right we've been told
nearly three hundred and ten thousand
people in the UK are in debt to loan
sharks with the benefit to criminals and
value of loans reaching nearly 36
million pounds
Jacquie has never used a loan shark but
as a single mum with six children she's
built up debt it'll take years to clear
I've been in a lot of debt where I don't
even read me lashes anymore I did come
through the door and I just pop them
straight in the bin and what debt and
even at the moment thousands do me
voluntary jobs and I work at the hive as
well just to keep myself out the house
and save on gas and electric through the
day to be honest go in through the night
time we go to bad alien stuff like that
despite working at the local youth
center she says she struggles just as
much as when she didn't have a job and
puts pressure on herself to provide for
her kids especially at Christmas each
kid I always when they under pound and
this year just said less and 400 pounds
and off she really need to be spending
400 pounds on each kid we didn't have
much growing up when I was a kid and I
always wanted to give them what I never
had debt often affects women more than
men because they earn less and have more
childcare pressure and in Mikayla's case
unpaid maternity mommy she's still
concerned the bailiffs will be back with
no credit to make calls we lent her a
phone to try and track down her
maternity she's now received some money
and an apology from her employers and
applied for a debt relief order we can
say we understand the data understand
they will never understand what it's
like because it never happened to them
what makes it we feel way more angry is
that it's it's Maternity it's put in
place to protect women
Michaela's hope of going to university
seems as distant as ever she fights to
keep the bailiffs at bay and keep the
roof over her kids heads luckily were
not begging so if you know on away the
Makayla
it was unpaid maternity for Sandra a
mistake to her benefits that pushed her
into debt you only say thank you no
animated of stench making ends meet
remains a daily struggle when did you
enact money this month
about the fourth jam with Dan because it
has exposed to getting hard to get at so
fossil was away at well
so now if you need to go to hospital
how'd you get there well if I was to go
to hospital now it would be a three to
four hour walk for me Sandra says she's
not wishing her life away when she turns
60 in three years free bus pass would be
life-changing meanwhile Mary's loan
repayments still haven't caught up with
her but she's anxious when her existing
benefits switched to the new system of
universal credit it will push her into
taking another eventually they are gonna
catch up but when you're in that
situation and you struggle and you're
really down in the dumps you know you
can turn to them and they will give you
money I'm dreading well I do go on
universal credit I will be getting alone
and when will that happen
they reckon about day if I'd be ready
next month people can't budget what they
haven't got deprivation offers little
way out of debt it's a losing battle an
endless cycle a little comfort knowing
so many families are in the same
position